[موسيقى]
مدرستنا مدرسه ثانويه زراعيه مهنيه قررنا
توسيع فكره تدريب طلابنا عمليا على
الزراعه ولم نكتفي ببعض النباتات في حديقه
المدرسه
في البدايه بنينا بيتا بلاستيكيا بدعم من
الوزاره ومن متبرعي وبعد ان بدا طلابنا
يحبون هذا العمل ويقبلون عليه ازداد عدد
البيوت البلاستيكيه وازدادت كميه الانتاج
لتصل اليوم الى اكثر من مليون ونصف مليون
نبته سنويا من نباتات الزينه الموسميه
في كل صباح ناتي الى هنا حتى قبل بدء
الحصص نوزع المهام بيننا والاساتذه
يساعدوننا جعلونا نحب هذا المكان ونريد
تطويره بشكل مستمر
متابعه نمو البذره الى ان تصبح نبته كبيره
امر ساحر جدبني الى هذا العمل وقد الى شخص
محب للبيئه واسعى لحمايتها بعد هذه
التجربه قررت احتراف هذا المجال والتخصص
في تصميم الحدائق والمتنزهات
طلابنا يتعلمون كل مراحل الزراعه عمليا
وعلى ارض الواقع ولدينا كثير من الطلاب
الاجانب في المدرسه وكل من يتخرج في
مدرستنا من السهل جدا ان يحصل على عمل في
اليوم التالي
تجربه حلوه بصراحه احنا تعلمنا يعني هوايه
هي عاده حلوه يعني انصح الكل يتعلمون لازم
يكون عندهم نباتات بالبيت يهتمون بها شيء
حلو حتى تتعلم النبات من نبات ايش يحتاج
وشلون تهتم بيه المجال حلو يعني مو شرط
مهندس جامعه تقدر تصير بستاني وتقدر تحصل
شهاده تقدير تشتغل بيها ورا المدرسه بدون
ما تدخل للجامعه
من اجل تدريب الطلاب على احد اهم عناصر
انجاح المشاريع وهو تسويق المنتج لم نكتفي
بالبيع البلديه والمؤسسات الرسميه بل
افتتحنا محلا للبيع في مركز المدينه
واخترنا اسما للعلامه التجاريه الخاصه بنا
كما اسسنا موقعا الكترونيا للبيع عبر
الانترنت نقوم من خلاله ببيع وشحن
نباتاتنا الى مختلف المحافظات التركيه في
اي مكان وعائدات المشروع تسلم للدوله
ويحصل الطلاب على جزء مهم من هذه العائدات
[موسيقى]